let's talk about nancy pelosi nancy you
reap what you sow
pro-abortion activist pro sets up
protest outside of speaker nancy
pelosi's san francisco mansion
now it wasn't the biggest crowd ever it
was like seven people i guess
so it's small right but but understand
that's a a very serious security issue
it is it really really is especially
like you know i think it's wrong to do i
don't think people should be going to
the homes of anybody it's like we got to
have areas that are sacred but you know
what nancy she praised the protesters
who were going out to the homes of the
supreme court justices
chuck schumer same thing
the president encouraged it i love the
hill ramp this piece that says joe biden
encourages illegal protests in front of
you know justice's homes or whatever
and i'm just like yo
the rule of law has broken down but at
the very least you see something like
this you reap what you sow
nancy pelosi probably doesn't care
though because you
you taxpayer are paying her security
bills
so she can advocate for it all day and
night people will then show up and
she'll be like the i don't care and then
the money we spend funds the security to
keep her safe when people show up at her
house
i don't understand why these people are
at her house right now did she say
something that pissed them off oh oh i
think they're they're she's supporting
henry cuellar in uh the district that
represents laredo texas on the right on
the border he is he's one of like the
last like pro-life dems and i'm sorry
anti-abortion pro-life them whatever um
and so there there's been on the
progressive side of things there's been
a lot of people who've been upset at
pelosi saying why are you supporting
henry cuellar when you're trying to
you know talk about
preventing roe v away from being
overturned so i i didn't see this until
until just now but i'm going to assume
that's part of the reason why i i i
think it might actually just be that
there is no logical argument there is
just power if it's good for the
revolution it's good if it's bad for the
revolution it's bad and nancy pelosi is
in a seat of power and they would prefer
one of their you know political
tribesmen or whatever to be in that seat
of power well i mean i was just covering
a a a pro-abortion protest in los
angeles and this was very far far left
people not just mainstream democrats and
and they were pissed that democrats uh
they they don't view them as
as technically on their side you know
the far left this is the party for
socialism and liberation that was like
the group that organized it so i mean we
see the you know the fringes right the
fringes don't view the main the
mainstream political parties as as being
different they view them as one of the
same and uh i'm gonna plug the book here
really quick i talk about that in in the
book when it comes to antifa and some of
the chazz uh occupiers during that time
but to bring it back i think that's why
again i don't know who who was there and
who organized that but that could be
just another thing too where they just
view the
pelosi being part of the political
establishment and political assessments
all one in the same i think there is
going to be a reckoning of all
reckonings in this country
we have this story from uh
post-millennial that goes along with
this glenn younkin slammed for
lackluster response to protest outside
scotus justice's home
yeah glenn younkin said we're going to
do a security perimeter and everyone's
like yo 18 usc blah blah blah whatever
says you can't demonstrate to try and
influence a court or a judge or whatever
and they're doing it and they get away
with it and the media comes out and acts
like egad the far right has called for
the arrest of people who've broken the
law and they they they they got will
chamberlain jack bosovic me and a few
other people in this daily beast fake
news article where i'm just like was it
petriezo did you write that maybe i
don't know there was a dude from occupy
who who tweeted at me and he was like 10
years ago you would have defended this
peaceful protest and i was like
10 years ago i filmed people deflating
police tires and said if you do
something in public you get seen doing
it like you take responsibility for your
actions and that non-violent civil
disobedience results in you getting
arrested i've always maintained that
position it's like it's so weird the far
left has gone so far left they're like
tim you would have agreed with our more
extreme position what happened and i'm
like no no you don't understand my
position hasn't changed you changed you
used to think we agreed because we did
and then you left and said why don't you
agree with me anymore
i think these people should be arrested
i think the police should walk up
take their hands very slowly put them in
cuffs bring them into the in the police
van or whatever take them to the station
they get charged with their little
misdemeanor you know protest charge the
judge says don't let me catch you there
again they get a court supervision
ruling which means basically nothing it
means don't go back and they made their
point they got press but they got
arrested and then if they go back and
get arrested again that gets a harder
sentence yeah but it's usually like a
weekend
well okay and so the the idea is there
has to be limitations
we have to say for these reasons we have
made something illegal but just because
something is law doesn't mean it's right
we talked about that with murder many
countries with despots were like the law
allows us to do it it's wrong there are
many laws that i think are wrong so what
do you do non-violent civil disobedience
you should get a slap on the wrist i
mean obviously defending on the severity
but i mean like if someone's going to
picket protest parade or otherwise
they shouldn't do it at someone's house
i think that's unethical and that's
immoral but if they do it is also at a
judge's house illegal and we have to
have the police say this is codified law
i don't think these people's lives
should be over i don't think they should
get a year in jail that's the maximum i
think the judge should be alive court
supervision let me not see you here
again tim enforcing the law is
insurrection i'm sorry oh yeah it's bad
for our democracy i found a good way to
change uh unjust law it's great the
united states is awesome because of 50
states 50 different legal systems kind
of so you if it's legal in one state and
illegal in the neighboring state you do
it in the legal state and you
communicate with people where it's
illegal in the illegal state and you
change their minds while you're doing it
where it's legal and then you have the
opportunity to kind of change the law
that way without actually having to go
disobey directly this is why i think
overturning roe v wade is actually very
important
it allows for this decentralized testing
pool of law
the 50 states it's quite brilliant each
state has jurisdiction over their state
to set laws
to a certain degree i respect supreme
court precedent on protecting
constitutional rights i think that i say
to a certain degree because i think they
get things wrong sometimes i think the
nfa should never have been allowed the
supreme court should have struck all
that down but even alito was like there
are limitations no i'm sorry not a
leader scalia
so
the idea is
taxes has laws new york has different
laws
eventually we can actually look at the
data and be like which place is better
granted there's different terrain
there's different resources but allowing
this allowing people to decide for
themselves in their own areas i think
actually would help preserve the union
would help make people live together
better because you know if you're like i
don't want to live in texas these laws
i'm going to move somewhere else well
new york's awaiting they're welcome
they're going to welcome you with open
arms chicago says abortion oasis if you
don't like what texas or oklahoma or
whatever is doing you can go right to
illinois and then you get carjacked
perhaps as you're driving around hold on
everywhere outside of chicago is red so
you can go to a you know red area and
you're probably going to be fine
less population dense i do think there
are um
there there are
important distinctions in what should be
federally protected across the board
like um non-discrimination on the basis
of race sex national origin etc the 1964
civil rights act i think that makes
sense but here's my favorite point in
all of this
at these protests there is no equality
under the law i see this as a clear
violation of the 14th amendment and that
these people are not being arrested
equality under the law means that if you
break the law you are held equal same as
everybody else right
these people are arguing that the 14th
amendment equality under the law
guarantees a woman's right to abortion
due to her right to privacy and medical
choices at the same time they're
actively defending that they don't get
criminally charged under existing
statute which is not equality under the
law so don't come to me and say the 14th
amendment guarantees shut up until you
say arrest me because i did break the
law i don't believe you're serious and
you're only trying to seize power and
you're a liar you're liars well i mean
look they're used to being above the law
i know you know a lot about this given
the book that you have written i'm
curious if uh you see any of this as
being a fallout from 2020 or no i mean
absolutely and and not not to get too
headed but i mean the reason why there's
so much concern about
more riots or some level of unrest if if
roe v wade is actually overturned is
because when you look at
how how much people were able to get
away with on such a large scale in 2020
in terms of looting in terms of
attacking police officers in terms of
just general lawlessness i mean they
were able to get away with a lot and
even the ones that were arrested i mean
portland's like the prime example but it
happened in other places like new york
city and in chicago and
so on and so forth and so that's why
you know why wouldn't they run the same
playbook because not only are they going
to get favorable media coverage like
they already have and not only they're
going to get the blessing of democrats
like like right now
uh there could be there's a very good
chance of not facing any consequences if
they do anything very very severe
so i mean we
part of the reason for the book is to
explain how we got here as a country and
and we are we are we've lost the plot on
just so many things and we are in such a
worse position to be able to confront
not even just like issues of racism or
or or abortion but it's just
because
people saw what violence worked to to a
degree it's okay why not just continue
that when we don't get what we want yeah
so what was the most shocking part about
the 2020 riots to you as someone who's
done extensive research on this
so
it was the main my main takeaway was
just how fragile society is
and it's it's pretty fragile i mean and
when we look at i mean 2020 was also
just such a unique year right because we
had the emergency covid we didn't know
too much about it and then all this
panic around it and then we also had a
very heated 20 election presidential
election and then there was a spark with
george floyd
so
when when you get these conditions just
right and that's why since the derek
chauvin trial there hasn't been really
anything
crazy happening because there have been
instances where i thought oh a police
action that's controversial maybe i
should go to that city and then nothing
happens but because there there needs to
be more build up kind of you know we
the country has gone through these
cycles of of of build up and then rage
with you know the start the summer rise
in 68 67
uh then we look at ferguson and then and
then now and then with minneapolis in
2020 2021
so even if
you know there's no mass violence post
overturning roe v wade i i would say
that it's kind of more like a jenga
block that's put into the build up to
that to where then maybe 2024 and that
presidential election and what will the
country look like then are we going to
be in severe economic
you know depression and downturn and
then you know when you when you put
people in these in these extreme
positions
uh through no fault of their own
especially
they're gonna do
crazy things and and you know a lot you
know doing these lockdowns i think
definitely
contributed to 2020 because
what was happening around just the
timing of everything it was it was late
may especially in a place like
minneapolis it was warming up people
were tired of staying home people lost
their jobs because of the lockdowns and
so they it was just
it was just a perfect uh tinderbox
essentially that all it needed was
something like a george floyd to happen
so
then leading to that i mean with
minneapolis
being there on the ground shortly after
after that it was it was crazy just how
the kind of the basic tenets of what we
know to be a civilized society just
wasn't there
in terms of uh you know for example i
was so used to protests not a flat not
affecting a couple blocks around where
the event was happening but i quickly
realized that there was no stores open
the the stores that were nearby they
were all being looted and so i ran out
of water
because i was out there all day and so i
had to grab water from from the target
that was looted because they were they
were putting they were putting um
all the stuff that hadn't been looted
into this giant uh pile
so that people could just grab whatever
they wanted so i just took what i needed
and then moved on but it was just it was
weird there's no public transportation
there was no uber there was a lift
clearly there's no cops i mean it was
just it was such a weird time and so
that really
was what was worrying going into 2021
thinking well is this kind of like the
new normal now in terms of just how the
immediate reaction to something that is
viewed as unjustified is then just
massive violence and lawlessness what
frustrates me with most stuff is like i
just want to know what the rules are
and if the rules were applied evenly
then i'd be like play ball you know what
i mean like let's have those arguments
but instead it's like they they
you ever play monopoly with someone who
just gets angry or angrier yeah a better
example is have you ever played pokemon
the card game i know many people in our
audience probably did when they were
kids and you probably had somebody where
it's like
yo my my uh you know gyarados does 50
damage to your dude and i win and start
getting angry because they're losing so
they just flip the table yo i watched
watch i once saw a kid pick up his razor
scooter and smack the other kid during
uh during a competition or contest or
whatever in this tournament so we were
at a game shop and there it was a
pokemon tournament or whatever it's back
when i was like 14 and some kid picked
up his scooter and just whacked the
other kid with it
that's what this feels like to me we are
having a political contest and have you
ever seen an argument where someone's
very calm and they're like i think x y
and z and the other person's getting
angrier and angrier that's what it is
and there's no moderator normally the
moderator should step in and be like yo
yo yo tone it down turn it down you're
yelling
you know let's keep it civil
in this political debate that has
reached the streets one side is getting
angrier and angrier and they're smashing
windows and starting fires and beating
people
because they're losing the argument
the moderator is the national guard
that's why i was asked at the beginning
of the show i'll ask you again do you
think that they should have sent in the
national guard day two of these
minnesota riots yeah absolutely and and
part of the problem and
because when when you look at los
angeles 92 right right after right after
rodney king and the trial that resulted
it did take a long time
for the national guard and even active
duty forces the marine corps was also
deployed during that time uh
it took a while for them to get there
and that that's part of the reason why
the riots were so destructive as they
were and it just seems like we're in
this constant cycle where
uh riot
response is updated and then because
it's sometimes decades until the next
one those those those policies and the
people in charge they leave and they
change and so things are outdated and
and probably another good example of
that was kenosha because part of the
part everyone was asking why did it take
so long for the national guard to to get
there and the sheriff i remember he said
during a press conference they didn't uh
they didn't follow the proper procedure
to officially request the national guard
he said that we got our wires crossed
how many and the same thing happened in
minneapolis they didn't the the mayor
jacob fry he fray whatever
he
they thought they put in the official
request to do it you know the proper way
to do it and they didn't just because it
no one does this how many people
got arrested for rioting in kenosha
oh i don't know that number well not
enough clearly what were there i i mean
people people got arrested
a few a few did i mean after the fact uh
but in terms of i mean
during the riots i didn't see besides
kyle
well that's the point
no the one the one arrest i do know
about was kyle rittenhouse
the one the guy who was trying to
protect the neighborhood who ran away
who rendered aid to the to the to even
the protesters and writers themselves
who fled for his life defended himself
and then tried turning himself in turned
himself in and went through the ringer
on all this and i'm like what about the
dude who bashed the old man with the
rock remember that yeah i i i
interviewed that man for the book was he
arrested uh no no no the old man i
interviewed the old man was that was it
was the guy who bashed him we don't know
i think it's fascinating you see you
said the national guard's the moderator
no they're not the moderator the
national guard is the bad parent where
one one child is sitting there playing
with his video game and the other kid
comes over and punches him and takes it
and the parents run over and go whoa
whoa stop fighting stop fighting or the
bad teacher who sees a kid gets get
tripped in the hall and then says zero
tolerance you're both getting detention
it's like dude one side is committing
violent acts and destruction
and the other side is like please stop
this and the national guard comes in or
the police come and say everybody calm
down everybody it's like the people who
came down there with kyle rittenhouse
were like we're going to protect these
buildings and render aid to the riders
themselves hope everyone's safe and then
what happens kyle is the one after
getting attacked who ends up going to
jail for two months and be having his
life destroyed fortunately at this point
it was not he's recovered from it
because justice was served but it's just
it is vomitous to hear these stories
over and over that's why i tell you when
when they announced we were in austin
when they announced the written house
verdict
people were crying
good people women were crying i don't
think i saw any dudes crying but i did
see women crying i made a cartoon about
that about people crying over written
house oh that's right you're the person
i think you guys will will appreciate
that one but with the whole situation
joy and relief oh okay well no there
were there were there were women it was
a surprise to be honest that were like
crying tears of joy and relief that this
kid was not going to be sent away for
life for protecting his his home in his
and where where he lived like and the
left right every lie gone across state
lines he didn't really live there his
mom dropped him off that didn't happen
all these lies all the lies all of the
lies it was all nonsense
and and
this is the guy and i watched a video
where an old man was bashed over the
head with a rock why wasn't that dude
who bashed the old man run through the
ringer why wasn't he the one standing
trial there is no moderator it wasn't
even a story well
it was to us that was the issue
with with the the
official response in kenosha was because
i mean the the governor tony evers he
only called up 150 national guardsmen
that was the initial response and that
was not nearly enough to actually secure
a town granted kenosha's not that big
compared to like minneapolis but when
but when the the city leaders of the
state leaders they did abdicate their
responsibility because again they didn't
want to in my opinion they didn't want
to seem like they were cracking down on
racial justice protesters and then that
leads a power vacuum to where then
people like kylo ren house you know with
good intentions like hey we're not going
to let people just destroy this town
anymore and we're going to we're going
to prevent you and we're going to stop
you so you just continue moving on doing
what you do and then
yeah something like raquel written how
situation is created and and yeah it was
i mean i was there for the second half
and i was there covering the trial
and
it was it was just it was just it was
just so
weird seeing how when being at the trial
and seeing the facts laid out because
you know i didn't know every single
aspect of it i didn't you know saw like
i said we saw the second half of it
but the the only good thing about the
trial is that it did lay everything out
you know unfortunately he did suffer a
lot to get to that point but there's
nobody who's going in there with an open
mind can then come away and say okay
yeah he definitely is a white
supremacist terrorist murderer that just
wanted to mass shoot everybody i mean if
that was the case he would have shot me
the daily beast
is now rated as fake news by news guard
because they have refused to correct all
of the fake news they wrote about cal
written house that's the that's the
principal reason why they've been
knocked down i love it because whenever
these daily beasts writers who just do
hit pieces on conservatives or
libertarians i just screen grab the news
guard thing and i'm like let me send
that to them you know like here you go
your fake news you are fake news and
it's not it's not even just it's not
even just them but i mean with
with with the whole no i mean not to
harp on kenosha too much but the the one
of the egregious examples of of the
mainstream media just misportraying what
was actually happening i mean cnn
multiple times
stated that jacob blake as a fact wasn't
was unarmed i mean they didn't they
didn't say appeared to didn't say it
looked like it i mean it was hard to
tell with the initial video didn't he
rape some woman uh that well so the the
two kids that were in the back seat of
the car and i mean this is what led to
the whole thing was that the woman that
he took the kids from that was who he
sexually assaulted and so that's why she
she had a protective order against him
and that's why the police were called in
so when the police were on their way
they were they said oh yeah by the way
he
he has this is his history and so he's
re-victimizing this woman and trying to
take her kids and then and and he's
armed with a knife and the taser
apparently didn't work and so i mean it
the video alone like when i first saw
the video i thought okay yeah this looks
bad but this this this doesn't just
happen a cop is not going to just plug
away
at this guy in the back but the whole
reason why he did is because he was
armed with a knife and he was about to
go into this car with two kids in the
back and take him away and so then the
officer had to think well then if
they're going to chase after them that
puts the two kids lives at risk who's
who's this guy do you guys know who this
is saints i don't know football
quarterback no who is he i don't know
people and the people in the chatter
saints player he's a guy more like the
ants he's holding the footballs and he's
got jacob blake on his helmet yeah uh
what he was convicted of assault
actually assaulting that one wasn't he
uh yeah i think so yeah and so she had a
protective order or protect a protective
order i don't know if he was convicted
but there was a productive order because
she made that yeah because she yeah she
had that the hell of that case against
him and so and and and it's not not even
just not even just not even just that i
remember i think the wnba also did
something drew brees is that what
they're saying drew brees yeah saints
quarterback imagine
imagine being like a celebrity and
putting like dahmer on your hat or
helmet kamala harris visited him in the
hospital yeah and and and this and he
said oh they're a good fan
sorry that's what she said to him too
tim what the laugh
from wikipedia says blake had a warrant
for his arrest from july based on
charges third degree felony sexual
assault trespassing and disorderly
conduct domestic abuse he wasn't
convicted he had a warrant for his
arrest okay innocent until proven guilty
but
just
imagining a scenario where you're like
i could respect innocent until proven
guilty
but the cops did not go there thinking
we're gonna we're gonna attack this this
unarmed guy they were like this is a guy
who's wanted for the arrest on felony
sexual assault charges we need to bring
him in and yes you do need to bring that
person in you can be innocent until
proven guilty and the state has a right
to stop you and those charges to be
levied against you he resisted he
grabbed a knife at the very least a guy
holding a knife who was wanted for
sexual assault and they're like i'm
going to put his name on my helmet
well and and that was to go back to my
initial point with with the media
initially saying as a fact not even
being speculative saying he was unarmed
i mean do you do you not think that
didn't incite people to come from
madison to come from chicago there was
guys that came from minneapolis to to to
take advantage of what was going on i
mean
that's why
it's so frustrating having been there i
mean that's i mean that was what the
title of my book right i mean because
cnn it's like because i met i've met
omar jimenez who was a reporter that was
msnbc no no no
cnn yeah i i think omar is a good
reporter and so on he was stating on the
ground that this was a riot that was
happening but it's like cnn has this
automatic reflexive response to just be
wrong on something and so the chiron
rider was yeah fiery of mostly peaceful
i mean that doesn't even make sense we
we used to call this group the tourists
where
when i would cover
uh protests or unrest these same people
were at every protest no matter what the
cause was
some of them actually bragged about
going to turkey and to china to advance
the protests in those countries and at
that point i'm just like you work for
the cia or something because like the
fact that you're in china organizing
protesters and turkey
i just have to wonder but no i don't i
don't genuinely think or accuse them of
being intelligence or anything i think
they're revolutionaries and i think they
just want to destroy
so you'd be in new york and someone
would be like trayvon martin and sure
enough there this group is my favorite
moment was the trayvon martin protest
when some of the tourists arrived
knew how to manipulate a protest march
got in front of it and then tricked the
march into going to wall street to
protest at the bull and the actual
organizers were like throwing their arms
in the air like why are we here we're
supposed to go to the police station but
instead like there's people jumping on
the bull and stuff and i'm like the
tourists took over
they these are they're like they're
extremist revolutionaries
this is what you need to understand
these people cannot engage in violence
unless they have a shroud of regular
people to protect them
they would love to go out with 10 people
and smash windows they would get caught
what they need is a shock moment that
will garner 200 people to come out they
then tell everybody show up in
solidarity wear all black so they can
and then they can destroy things smash
things burn things etc and it's
impossible for the state to figure out
who did it
well in in one of my
one of the things that is also
frustrating about having covered all
these riots is that there are some
people on the left who like to point to
right-wing infiltrators i mean they in
minneapolis there's umbrella man that
they accuse of being a being an
infiltrator uh they say that this
boogaloo boy was the one that set the
third present to him fire and so let's
just say for the sake of argument to
borrow from ben shapiro okay for the
sake of argument king there we go
let's just say yeah it was all
right-wing infiltrators that set the
third pre-song on fire and as someone
who was there i can tell you that none
of the actual black lives matter
protesters slash rioters had any issue
of who said who set the building on fire
i mean they that there was a whole
reason why they were there because they
wanted to actually set it on fire with
the officers still inside they were all
celebrating they were all happy that
this was on fire so even if
that you know this was the work of
extreme right wing trying to make the
movement look bad i can tell i can tell
you
being outside there that everyone was so
happy and they wanted to continue to the
other precinct which was the closest one
was the fifth precinct and they
thankfully weren't successful in
destroying that but it's just it but
they can't it's like they can't accept
the rhetoric that they that they say i
mean all the time you hear revolution
you hear we gotta do direct action but
as soon as there is direct action and on
a pretty big scale they want to back up
and say well actually it wasn't us it
was people are trying to make us look
better it's like no you you're
practicing what you're preaching and
also just the fact that other people
were were charged with setting the uh
third person remember that guy who stole
the body armor and like the gun or
something
like from the burning building he stole
body armor i remember something like
that yeah one guy i do remember one guy
who went into the before that it got
sent on fire came out with like a ryan
helmet and and he held it up in the air
and everyone was cheering i think about
some people are dumb sending in the
national guard like like i think that
trump was afraid because he was the
president i think this is was kenosha
was afraid that uh
we have another may 4th kent state
shooting on our hand where the national
guard fired into a crowd of college
students killed four people
but firstly it wasn't like a peaceful
protest like at kent state that was
relatively peaceful from what i know it
was a violent riot uh even at that stage
they were i mean they were rioting day
one i believe i i think
that probably a bunch of republicans
said no no no don't stop the writing the
writing is good the rioting will get you
to win elections
that's that's
i mean i don't know if that's treason
treason involves another country no it's
not true sedition what would you call
that i'm willing to bet there were i
don't know if they said this to trump
but i'm willing to bet that they were
republican strategists who are like the
more riots they are the better our
chances come the end of the year
well that's obviously not the case we've
seen the proof is with the past we see
that that is not the case if you let
riots burn everything dissolves into no
it no no it it black lives matter after
george floyd had its highest approval
rating ever in aggregate at 51 percent
and then it dropped to 9
uh
oh i'm getting those numbers wrong it
was like 26 net approval and dropped to
like percent net approval there because
he didn't he didn't stop the rides he
didn't get involved because the riots
as soon as they started rioting public
support collapsed i think it went from
like 51 percent to like 40 percent and
that well well part of the problem is
that it just continued happening i mean
when when everything first started i
initially thought that okay i'll cover
minneapolis and i'll go home and that'll
be it but then things things kept
happening no matter how thin of an
excuse that
that they that they had they were they
were they were going to write because
that was this is what i was saying
before the automatic response and
what really hit me was when i was
covering a riot in wauwatosa wisconsin
which is probably about like an hour and
a half northwest of of kenosha where it
was a black officer who shot a black
teenager who was armed with a gun had
shot the gun previously he was pointing
the gun at the responding officers
and but this was all free george floyd
and pre-covet and so that's why no one
knew about this and so since the
milwaukee district attorney was making
decision whether or not to criminally
charge uh the officer in a post-george
florida world that's why there was riots
in the first place but the thing is is
just that
being in that town i mean it really
looked like my hometown of wheaton i
mean they were there it was a black
lives matter caravan from madison that
made their way to wauwatosa and as soon
as they hit the city of limits they
started destroying everything in insight
including thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you